korwisi hat gigantische kobalt und
kupfervorkommen gemessen an dem wert der
bodenschätze müsste jeder einwohner hier
im luxus schwelgen ausländer machen
riesige gewinne aber wir bekommen nichts
ab
das leiden der menschen im kongo geht
weiter die chinesen kaufen das ganze
land
ich weiß dass dies keine gute arbeit für
die kinder ist
ich weiß dass es nicht gesund für sie
ist aber welche wahl habe ich für zwei
tage arbeit bekommen sie weniger als 2
dollar
menschen sterben hier und unsere kinder
wachsen in dieser rauen umgebung auf sie
werden rebellen
es kommt zur vergewaltigung kinder
werden es braucht um diesen säcken mit
der rohstoffe unseren wohlstand verbaut
wird er in akkus von handys tablets und
elektroautos statussymbole für unseren
luxus die männer frauen und kinder die
ihn zu tage bringen müssen wissen nicht
was und ob sie heute abend überhaupt
etwas zu essen bekommen
[Musik]